we are now three days after the Iowa
caucus and almost all of the results
have now been reported the updated
Democrats delegate count shows Pete
buddha-heads with a razor-thin lead over
Bernie Sanders both have about 26% there
followed by a live Elizabeth Warren Joe
Biden and Amy Klobuchar Ed O'Keefe is in
Manchester New Hampshire for us Edie
good morning you've been covering the
primary campaign there with the updated
Iowa results are any candidates changing
their strategies a little bit Tony good
morning there are just a few days left
until Tuesday's primary so no time to
waste and former Vice President Joe
Biden especially is trying to
distinguish himself from fellow moderate
Pete Buddha judge he did so in part by
discussing something last night that he
rarely discusses in public looking in
the mirror with a flashlight of my face
because you get embarrassed because you
could you you you can torch your face
and it's embarrassing while opening up
extensively about his stutter as a child
former Vice President Joe Biden made a
passionate plea we just have to reach
out a little more for people mad we
don't do it enough we got to heal this
country earlier he'd admitted political
vulnerability after a poor showing in
Iowa I am NOT gonna sugarcoat it we took
a gut punch in Iowa Biden then focused
his attention on his opponents
especially former mayor Pete Budaj it's
a risk to be just straight up with you
for this party to nominate someone who's
never held on office higher than mayor
of a town of a hundred thousand people
in Indiana the former vice president is
hoping the contrast makes a difference
in New Hampshire as the Iowa results so
far show 38 year-old Buddha jej was able
to find broad support across the state
especially in rural counties and across
all age groups but close behind Buddha
judges Bernie Sanders who's polling at
the top in New Hampshire we're gonna end
the divisiveness in this country and
we're gonna bring people together
whoever is the eventual Democratic
nominee knows they'll need to try
reconstructing the Obama coalition
abroad Alliance of voters who came from
different backgrounds
she's a janitor's daughter who has
become one of the country's fiercest
advic
for the middle class that explains why
Biden is no longer the only one claiming
to be the heir to the former president's
legacy mayor Dean Berg and President
Obama worked together in the fight for
gun safety laws Bloomberg will not be
joining fellow contenders on the debate
stage here in New Hampshire tomorrow
night the only debate before the primary
but he might end up on a debate stage in
Nevada or South Carolina later this
month
now that the DNC has changed its rules
and eliminated a requirement that
candidates have certain donors gale of
course the multi billionaire Bloomberg
is paying for his campaign all by
himself
yes making that very clear thank you
very much ad